hello everyone I will on it welcome to
my channel today I am playing the outer
world basically this is gonna be another
live review let's go hard because that's
how I like it
that's what she said so in the beginning
of this game you are on a ship and it
turns out that the ship is screwed
basically so I believe a guy comes to
try to save use what's happening here
yeah there is okay he is where we spend
my whole life in the character crater
and I will tell you I already know
because I've already played this pot
it's extremely extensive and I really
love that about this game it feels like
I haven't played an RPG like this in a
hot minute so what do I care about I
definitely care about these two only two
more points
I should probably shouldn't put anything
below average I don't want to use
handheld weapons we are going to want to
use ranged weapons critical hit chance
and guns long guns and heavy weapons
aptitude
might do a full beard
yep doing it okay again it's so a few
colas so right now we're in like a
dropship takes you to the planet below
where you have some of you first
encountered slash interactions see what
I said about it being colorful it is
really pretty and I feel like with the
the wildlife like I like that they did
that um a lot of the wildlife the
animals are just really creatively
designed as well it just doesn't look
great like that log you can see the
texture on the top but the whole thing
looks blurry to me I don't know uh uh oh
this is technical time dilation
that's my legs I'm just talk to this
dude alright so this guy walks four
spaces choice and in this world
basically people are so tied to
corporations like factions that they
will kind of do anything they say it is
like your life it's like a religion it's
this game if you want to buy into it
totally as commentary on capitalism I
think it's really well written I want to
take his gun he has a gun I would like
to take it here we go this way I feel
like even compared to New Vegas cuz of
course he doesn't know this is made by
obsidian who made in Fallout New Vegas
this game has really extensive dialogue
options where there are often choices
for you to do different things all right
I'm off you can't mean it's gun we are
good to go
sorry Phineas everything's good Oh
didn't mean to do that okay here we go
tactical time dilation is a a
complication stemming from your being
revived after an extended hibernation
which i think is actually a very cool
way for them to build us into the law
instead of using something like that's
where the technology makes you slow down
you have the ability to slow down time
sort of as an accident as a result of
you being in hibernation in space for a
really long time well that looked to me
like it was right in the head but I
guess not later dude
it's easier if you run at me come on
definitely does more damage at close
range obviously this is a handgun it's a
the other guy died oh okay
hello space huh how are you I don't know
that might dissuade is high enough I'm
gonna try it yes
management's real good at cost-benefit
analysis you're very important so
important never met someone more
important in my life you're right
all right well go do the thing let's see
how well they do I wonder if they'll
kill anyone they did they really did I'm
very proud of you now let me take all
this off noted hello yes seriously one
day a videogame will let me a cyber
lesbian and I can't wait I am programmed
to take orders exclusively from Captain
Hawthorne I can do it just let me do it
look how glorious the level up screen is
it's so good ok here is where you get to
see aunt Cleo management training and
I've been promoted
ok part this is what we want to go yep
skills and perks ok healthy uh faith
health fifty percent is a lot and I
think you can upgrade these multiple
levels as well okay if this is it's just
some real good RPG [ __ ] just to show you
guys the rest of this this is basically
you know general everything and then
reputation depends on which of the major
factions or companies
see that's industries it's obviously an
industry their governments or whatever
it's how they feel about you because you
all gonna have to make some choices in
this game with who you align with ok
let's get out of the ship rings around
the planet it's actually just again I
think this game is really pretty even
though I find it graphically
unsatisfying there's an aurora borealis
really big planet I feel like this is a
gravity nightmare frankly but it looks
nice I don't have the weapons I want but
let's just
take a lot of hits man you can dodge a
lot of their shots yeah but I will say
part of why I made a particular build
for this character that is not focused
on close combat is because aside from
when I have a shotgun I don't love the
combat in this game like none of those
shots felt satisfying to me I don't know
okay what do we have right now level 3
spaces choice tech skills condition what
does it give me
I don't need tech skills handed me Lee
one-handed melee of course they are
because that would be what these guys
are stealth skills I'll take that that's
cool
hi friends they're all very stiff I will
say that I'll talk to you it's not mine
I stole it
I didn't think about that though either
that is cool that because I'm wearing
this right now the dialogue options of
different yeah mail burglar um you know
bug yeah this mofo this game has a lot
of talking and should be interesting to
stream because of that I don't know how
audiences alike of it because I mean
it's an RPG it's about the character you
play and how you interact with other
characters there is a lot of talking if
you don't like talking you're probably
not going to like the outer wilds and
you know the the dialogue options are
really extensive in some places every
faction every town has its own law that
people have their own beliefs they have
different leaders for different reasons
why they like for different reasons it
is so fleshed out if you don't like
talking I can't imagine you getting much
out of this game I'm all for it
personally I don't know the really long
loading screen which again I think it's
really pretty but oh boy all day long
yeah I'll be honest it pretty much looks
like space fallout so there's that oh I
didn't mean to do that just tap that lb
hi friends anyone wanna have a chat hi
resident would you like to talk
apparently not this looks like a cannery
was gonna say it looks like an official
building but I suppose it probably is
the town Lido works for corporation etc
etc let's go alright hey bud strangely
yes
you read I was told I should talk to you
that me my ships yeah Nance repairs mr.
Thompson ain't liable to be keen on
dismantling it there's a power regulator
in the old botanical lab it's mostly
abandoned so all that power is being
laundered
go down to the geothermal plant reroute
power from the botanical district over
it seems to be fishy once their power
shut down you would have their regulator
and be along on your way it seems rude
yep I was not entirely sure how to tell
you this the botanical labs are not
legally inhabited but I guess I'll go
find out what those people are about and
decide how I feel about it that seems a
little more reasonable before you go to
the plant I want you to stop by the
botanical lab speak to their leader
where did she go sure yeah okay why do
we have to talk in the elevator sorry I
you just want to get out of here and you
likely don't stop being so awkward it's
just mr. Thompson has his own view on
matters on account of it's his job but
that's not the only thing I figured
ah that is true he didn't but nope top-1
- mr. Thompson the person's a gear do
you know Adelaide miss McDevitt no she
was a real important person a florist
made all the food tasty it's cool law
there is a lot of lore in this to the
weather they make different kinds of
meat max huh be folk just said how did
they manage to make character models
look but with good and bad and I kind of
think that's the case for everything in
this game okay
yeah I'll talk to the vicar drag it out
dog this is all ready as you can see
this particular mission is branching a
lot a lot of different people to talk to
you a lot of perspectives and they don't
give it to you straight away which I
think I really like hello Vika max it's
creepy alright let's ask about about the
religion I'm curious who are not
satisfied with their work or satisfied
with nothing so even religion is used to
feed the corporation's I love that I
think I really like this well building I
think it's great there's a name for when
games have light go through likea
college and you can see it but they did
a really bad job of it it's really good
in like uncharted 4 it's mind-blowing it
looks actually like the light is coming
through that eeeh cartilage and exactly
where it should be this is an attempt at
that that just looks like they put
pleura paint on what is mr. Thompson
asked you to do cut off power to add
lights to sodas depriving them of safety
from the Marauders and yes sir life I
can see why they yes what do you think
about all AIDS group they rejected the
order of society and live beyond the
walls so thoughtfully Pro why are
spacers choice patrons that's does that
political stance responsible this is
super interesting you guys I'm very
interested in the fact that we have the
town head the religious figure he is
obviously showing a political alignment
as a capitalist religion it'sit's just
like committing to building a character
in a world that is already very good at
well building and every character is
like this it's kind of mind-blowing it's
just I just think it's really well
written in a way that like wasteland is
wasteland too is that I didn't feel like
fallout 4 was right blow up this dude
why did that not work didn't even kill
him they just take a lot okay I did get
a headshot there because it went yellow
just takes so much damage yeah okay it's
just maybe more specific than I thought
like maybe I'm shooting them in the neck
this isn't gonna go well that's two
headshots no we bailing yeah of course I
don't have any other I don't have any
other weapons am i doing is too soon
oh oh oh hey bud all right it's my first
melee weapon that worked pretty well I
don't like the way the camera moves when
I'm trying to do
melee [ __ ] you I was healing that's
[ __ ] they're all stats that effect
you up going and I do have them enacted
cool more loading screens but at least
the odd is really pretty but the kind of
had to do that cuz there's so many
[ __ ] large screens I feel like all of
the female characters I've encountered
so far other than Parvati have been
really hot [ __ ] like not that they're
literally [ __ ] I mean they're like
they're like boss [ __ ] like they're
hard I wonder if that's a thing that'll
be consistent or if it's like because of
the circumstances but first next I want
to talk to Adelaide priorities are you
rattle ade
hey addy weird camera though okay
resent me to make peace with you which
one this one I don't want to stop beef
why would you agree to his plans
you can't pose a yes he's got a
regulator you want ship parts you ought
to rip them out of the canneries guts
and leave us be if you're going down to
the plant
away from Edgewater and toward our end
of the grid I don't know what to do
neither of them have given me enough
reason to beef I feel like I want to
learn more about the people in this town
oh hey that's a rooster that's a whole
ass for oh it's chicken of course this
guess you can't talk to it
hey bud
good chat good chat my logic is that if
I help Reed I'm not destroying the lives
of everyone in that town I don't feel
good about it but when it comes to the
greater good it seems like the right
thing to do
stealth is an option probably that's
what I'm testing right now we'll see if
it works
as long as he goes to the right we
should be okay
what frozen pixel said man that's pretty
crappy that your character is gonna [ __ ]
over a bunch of people either way just
preparing a [ __ ] I like it it's takes a
high I have to think about it you know
it's not like baby's first RPG where
what you're doing has no consequence and
I think that's sort of the pot the point
of this world is extremely capitalist
and inherently really selfish factions
out for themselves known out for the
good of people so I think it makes sense
that it would challenge you in that way
also yeah I guess stealth is possible
but that was not at all fun it was
actually very dumb and basic that's my
review of stealth attack [ __ ] another
one
these boys are strong
oh come on come on come on come on take
it take it take it
[ __ ] I need better weapons so bad let's
go and actually spend some money
something like this should not be this
hard to kill oh look at you you're tiny
okay yeah oh my god where is it where is
it where is it oh [ __ ] [ __ ] no no no no
Oh lawdy oh [ __ ] oh god it would be
tight if that shut them down it did not
hmm robot phobia
when they're attacking a party you're
not as effective as you should be hmm so
I want to take that you're right I am
scared of the robots oh yes great I love
that okay if we go great okay was that a
jump-scare yes I'm going to kill several
people please tell me what you think
I'm unsetting we've been losing workers
year after year corporate hardly ever
since replacements there's barely enough
salt tuna to fill our bellies anymore
that's what I was worried about
I agree neither do the people who left I
think I have to give the power to
Edgewater and try to talk those people
into going back I don't want to kill all
those people
I'm sorry
thank you guys for watching I feel like
this is a very good example of what this
game is all about my synopsis off the
plane for this two hours and the
probably three hours I played even
before this it's that this game is a
little bit ugly but very colorful which
I like it's like I'm a little bit
confused by my stance they're very good
people who like PGS and reading and want
to get invested in actually role-playing
a character I do not like the combat at
all I know the comment will be a lot
easier when I get better weapons rather
than just this one pistol but so far I
think it's a little unsatisfying I don't
feel like there's enough recoil from the
weapons I like the characters I like the
way they developed I think I'm gonna get
extremely sucked into this game because
it's the kind of thing that I like
alright thank you all yeah games out
really soon so check it out and I do
have to say thank you to private
division for getting me a coat so yeah
I'll see you guys next time